♪♪
>> Kimberly: THIS IS A
FOX NEWS ALERT.
ANOTHER SHAKE-UP TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CABINET.
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCING HIS
REPLACING VETERANS AFFAIRS
SECRETARY DAVID SHULKIN.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED:
"I AM PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THAT I
INTEND TO NOMINATE HIGHLY
RESPECTED ADMIRAL
RONNY L. JACKSON, MD, AS THE NEW
SECRETARY OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
IN THE INTERIM, HONORABLE
MIKE WILKIE OF DOD WILL SERVE AS
ACTING SECRETARY.
I AM THANKFUL FOR
DR. DAVID SHULKIN'S SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY AND TO OUR GREAT
VETERANS!"
JESSE, DOES THIS COME AS A SHOCK
OR SURPRISE?
>> Jesse: WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
ABOUT THIS.
THIS WAS AN OBAMA HOLDOVER,
SHULKIN.
WE KNOW WHAT HAPPENED AT THE VA
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THEY HAD LONG WAITING LINES AND
BUREAUCRATS WERE GIVING BONUSES
FOR SERVICE THEY DID NOT PROVIDE
WHILE PEOPLE DIED WAITING FOR
CARE THEY NEVER RECEIVED.
THIS GUY WAS BROUGHT IN AND
APPARENTLY WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE
CLEANED THINGS UP.
I DON'T KNOW HOW EFFECTIVE HE
WASN'T DOING THAT.
THE PRESIDENT CAMPAIGNED ON
TAKING CARE OF VETERANS AND HE
WAS VERY PROUD TO SIGN A NEW VA
ACCOUNTABILITY BILL.
IT WAS EASIER TO FIRE PEOPLE WHO
WERE UNDERPERFORMING.
THERE WERE TRAVEL ISSUES WITH
HIM.
HE MIGHT HAVE RUN AFOUL OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ON SOME ETHICAL
ISSUES WITH RESPECT TO THAT.
HE HAD TO GO.
THE PRESIDENT IS NOT GOING TO
KEEP SOME GUY AT THAT AGENCY
THAT'S NOT 100% BEHIND THE
VETERANS AND CAN'T AFFORD TO
ALLOW ANY SORT OF PERCEPTION OUT
THERE THAT THE PRESIDENT IS NOT
TAKING CARE OF THE VETS THAT HE
SO DEEPLY VALUES.